[Music]
we're distributing meals for
those who have food insecurity
it's a part of a partnership with
danielle king
that happy foodie has been able to
participate in
it's really important to us because we
founded a foodie fund
that is designed to bring meals to those
that have food insecurity
and danielle has been a partner in that
and so
she's using her influence to help get
other contributions
so that we can continue to do this and
bring more meals to
those who have food insecurity today
we're here to have a food drive
with a three-sport food bank that
one of my partners happy foodie has
donated and over six distribution places
in las vegas that's incredible i stopped
actually in the middle of street
to see how many people there are and it
was as far as i can see
to be honest how many people lined up
but it just kind of gives you a hit of
reality you know
you don't realize that it is still
before 9 a.m and they've been lining up
since
hours and they have to find out when the
next food drive is
through through square food bank and to
be here it's
this is their livelihood people forget
how many people are actually still
hungry even to this day
and it's actually a real thing and it's
a preventable cause that we can all work
towards the organization itself the
volunteers that come out it's their own
time you know they're not they're not
getting paid they're out here helping
and helping their community